Miller its Jensen the way I play Deus Ex
mankind divided might not be the same
way you play when I play Adam Jensen I
avoid conflict drink all the alcohol I
find and stop bad guys from doing
terrible things by releasing pheromones
into the air and then asking politely
but every obstacle in the cyberpunk
world of mankind divided has multiple
solutions provided you unlock certain
abilities and the game rewards you for
achieving things with their own
personally preferred method no matter
what that may involve for conflict there
are more than enough tools for a direct
approach a variety of lethal and
non-lethal guns grenades and ammo which
fire and explode wonderfully and helpful
cybernetic augmentations that can give
you temporary buffs like heavy armor or
slowing down time alternatively there
are robust stealth mechanics filler you
slip quickly from cover to cover see
enemy sight lines or straight up turn
invisible for a while
you could also use hacking skills and
have fun taking advantage of the game's
futuristic setting turning century
robots
automated turrets and the environment
against aggressors but no matter how you
decide to go about solving a problem in
Deus Ex
there's always a thrill when you succeed
and the game dishes out experience
points no matter which actions you take
this means killing enemies is as
satisfying as slipping past them without
raising suspicion punching through a
wall is just as fulfilling as stealing a
keycard and using the door the great
thing is there's no superior way to
complete a task mankind divided also
introduces a handful of new augmentation
abilities for Jensen on top of those
introduced in the previous game human
Revolution some of these new orbs are
more interesting than others though
remote hacking for example is an
invaluable tool for disabling automated
obstacles at a distance and the Icarus
Dash is a great tool for discrete
traversal
however the Tesla peps and nano blade
abilities achieve similar effects to
some of the game's more conventional
weapons they stun and kill enemies from
a distance there are some advantages to
using them but most of the time I wish
I'd spent points elsewhere mankind
divided continues with the series's
portrayal of a cyberpunk dystopia with a
focus on the politics around people with
cybernetic implants and the subsequent
implications on the definitions of
humanity the plot involves countless
government bodies corporations security
forces underground resistances the
Illuminati and the events of day sex
frame suspicion on literally every
organization and individual in
this makes it impossible to trust any
one character other than Jensen as he
attempts to find evidence revealing the
motives and masterminds behind a number
of terrorist acts deciding which
organisation to aid and which to deceive
during pivotal plot moments is grueling
because everything is so unyieldingly
gray but the lack of a clear antagonist
or driving purpose can lead to temporary
disillusionment with no one enemies
standing in the crosses for too long the
upside to this is that mankind divided
doesn't feature the ill-received
boss battles that appeared in human
Revolution and remains purely as a
series of increasingly challenging
infiltration and investigation scenarios
all of which can be solved in the manner
of your choosing the world of days x is
an easy one to get completely absorbed
in the city hubs all based in Prague are
where you'll spend most of your time and
are stunningly well realised the streets
are full of life and bowled me on
advertising the futuristic buildings are
constructed among old world European
architecture and dilapidated housing and
make the city believable
you'll revisit locations and walk the
same routes regularly gaining an
intimate knowledge of the streets and
structures and this knowledge is
incredibly useful and satisfying to draw
upon later in the game as new situations
arise one hub is a stunningly
claustrophobic and oppressive
multi-level slum filled with ramshackle
apartments and dense marketplaces which
maybe just want to stop every few feet
just to soak it all in spaces are filled
with character densely packed with
discoveries to make about its
inhabitants and are exceptionally
curated with subtlety you might say push
some unremarkable boxes in a shop aside
to pleasantly discover that someone has
hidden some rainy day cash behind them
you might also notice that despite is
constant over-the-top broody demeanor
Adam Jensen absolutely loves eating
colorful sugary cereal additionally a
portion of the game's side quests are
not explicitly marked and are only found
by going a day away to talk to certain
people you may have otherwise run right
past mankind divided also include an
asymmetrical online early competitive
mode called breach breach uses the
first-person combat stealth and remote
hacking mechanics of Deus Ex in brief
visually abstracted challenge missions
with focus on both score chasing
speedrunning and beating other players
the tone of breach is very different to
the main camp
with the emphasis not so much on the
breadth of options available to you but
taking the path of least resistance
after playing through the main story
campaign as a pacifist breech felt like
it gave me much more license to
experiment without consequence racing
around like a maniac shooting non-human
enemies in the face and causing general
chaos as I tried to climb the speedrun
leaderboard as he progressed new
conspiracy stories arise and unlocking
the details requires you to successfully
collect gems in particular missions
these are interesting to take in but
feel out of place within breach but turn
all confusion aside breach is still a
pleasing way to hone your skills with
deus exes action mechanics Deus Ex
mankind divided refines and reinforces
the defining foundations of the series
it creates challenging situations and
gives players the tools and flexibility
to deal with them in a multitude of ways
all within an absorbing cyberpunk world
although it's not a significant
departure from human Revolution mankind
divided is still a uniquely fulfilling
experience and one which feels rare in
games today